ach ja die weihnachts gurke diese
altehrwürdige und heiß geliebte deutsche
tradition von der ich schon so viel
gehört habe aber jetzt bin ich im kadewe
in berlin deutschlands größtem kaufhaus
und kann keine einzige in den
weihnachtsbäumen entdecken wo sind die
ganzen garten zum glück habe ich selbst
eine dabei aber noch mal von vorn
ich komme aus den usa und dort glauben
viele menschen dass sich alle deutschen
eine gurke in den baum hängen und viele
us-amerikaner pflegen diese angeblich
deutsche traditionen die person die die
weihnachts gruppe zuerst am baum
entdeckt bekommt ein extra geschenk
aber ganz ehrlich seitdem ich in
deutschland lebe habe ich hier noch
keine einzige weihnachts gruppe gesehen
ich frage mal ein paar deutsche die ihre
weihnachtseinkäufe erledigen
zeigen sie dieses jahr ein weihnachts
bürger auf ihren weihnachtsbaum
ich glaube dass es eine andere tradition
also es ist keine deutsche tradition
bitte eine weihnachtskarte gruppe ist
nicht mal ein lieblingsgemüse
weihnachtsglocken weihnachtskarte
bleiben ich weiß nicht was eine
weihnachts gurke ist davon was macht man
damit sogar den weihnachtsmann muss sich
die gurken tradition erklären
tatsächlich haben 91 prozent der
deutschen laut einer umfrage noch nie
davon gehört
wenn das also gar keine deutsche
tradition ist wo kommt ihr denn her und
wie ist sie in die usa gelangt ein
kleiner weihnachtszauber bringt mich in
das bergdorf lauscher in thüringen
hier beginnt meine spurensuche
wenn sich irgendwo jemand mit dem
ursprung von weihnachtsschmuck auskennt
dann in lauscha seit 1597 gibt es hier
glasbläser und seit der mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts stellen sie
weihnachtsdekorationen her
glasbläser michael haberland führt
seinen familienbetrieb in vierter
generation seine handgefertigten artikel
verkauft der weltweit auch die
weihnachtsglocken von ihrer existenz
erfährt aber auch er erst auf einer
reise nach kalifornien
[Musik]
wenn du klaus preiser bist machst du
auch gurken man denkt sich nichts dabei
wenn das zur zweite fragt da denkt man
oh okay beim dritten habe ich gesagt
dann wurde mir eben erzählt in
deutschland ist es so weit ist tradition
und zither da hängt sich jedoch nur
getrennt
an dem baum weiß jeder amerikaner oder
so ist nur kein deutscher zurück zu
hause schaut er sich die alten glas
formen seines großvaters aus den 1930 er
jahren an gesucht und wurde ich kurz
fündig und seitdem inzwischen verkauft
er seine gurken an kunden in japan
norwegen in der schweiz und natürlich in
den usa aber wenn auch er diese
tradition erst seit kurzem kennt wo
kommt sie dann her
tatsächlich ranken sich einige legenden
um den ursprung der weihnachts gruppe
eine stammt aus dem amerikanischen
bürgerkrieg ein gefängniswärter soll
einem verhungernden deutschstämmigen
soldaten eine gurke zu essen gegeben
haben
der mann überlebte und ging danach jedes
jahr eine gurke in seinen baum
andere sagen es war der us amerikanische
unternehmer frank dabei juhu der ab 1880
deutschen weihnachtsschmuck in die usa
importierte vielleicht sollte ich den
mann fragen der diese weihnachtsstadt am
besten kennt ich besuche bürgermeister
norbert zitzmann in der ilias farb
lastete die älteste die hier noch
existiert begründet 1853 bürgermeister
kennen sie die tradition der weihnachts
brücke kommt aus deutschland
was ist denn das und wir erfuhren dass
man in übersee meint dass diese gurke
aus lauscha käme und ein ganz besonders
wichtiger weihnachtsartikel ist ich
denke hier und ein geschickter marketing
man hat s erfunden
seit dieser zeit werden dort tatsächlich
gucken hergestellt weil viele menschen
meinen das typische wasser auskommt ist
die gurke
ich bin immer noch nicht schlauer aber
es gibt noch hoffnung
ich frage gerd roß bei seinen recherchen
für die stadt über glaswaren aus lauter
ist er auch auf die gurken tradition
gestoßen
was haben sie darüber herausgefunden
raus gericht dass es doch bei einigen
familien der brauch bauer einen
bestimmten ein bestimmtes ornament im
baum zu finden um dann das größte oder
das erste geschenk zu sehen und daraus
wurde dann die christmas berge
weihnachts kurve gemacht
vielleicht werden wir nie erfahren was
es mit der weihnachts gurke wirklich auf
sich hat
auf jeden fall ist sie eine lustige
erfindung und eines tages kennen sie
vielleicht auch zu deutschen ich hab da
eine idee
[Musik]